We are not here because we are happy.
We are here because we are angry.
We are angry about the state of this country.
We are angry about the living conditions
that our fellow South Africans are subjected to.
We are angry that 30 years later,
school children have to risk their lives
crossing full rivers just to get to school.
We are angry
that women like myself live in fear in this democracy
because this government
has not provided safe spaces for us,
even in our own homes.
I am angry that millions of people go to bed hungry
when there is more than enough food to feed everybody.
And there is more than enough money in this country
to feed everybody.